season one stuck out for me I had to do
that bloody nude scene
um anyone else here have to
do yeah you have to do
that semi semi a
semi
okay that one time guys you heard here
first I don't particularly want to do
another one again that I'm still finding
bits of pubic hair stuck to
me it's my own course can you say there
a little joke about that somebody turned
up wor
pathetic yeah the first time I saw my
myor um which is what they called it um
it was a prosthetic pis about this size
um it was Richard M he kept running up
to me in the car park and he had
strapped on to
him make your prosthetic Christian I'm
okay but also they actually made the
funny thing is they actually made two of
them um there was one with like TI tight
afro pube hair which obviously I've got
gray hair guys which obviously wasn't
mine and there was one more like me so
do you want me to tell the story it's
really
awful I think definitely tell that story
I'll do it really quickly cuz you guys
have heard up 15,000 times right
basically they said it was a close set
um there wasn't there was like 300
people there um they made these really
horrible prosthetic penis
panties that horrible had to be CGI out
they had to plant the pubic hair into my
own pubic
hair yeah awful to a makeup girl um and
they had to panted to my own skin color
while it was on me um yeah so we had to
do the same it was in a Forest Glade and
carried off I said
Belfast and
um and it was reing the the power
generators kept going out and um there
were two are the children here just
okay there were two pheasants who wanted
to love each
other on on each side of the of the set
and every time I came out in this
prosthetic penis pants um the pheasants
would call to each other and
go I guess so we had to we had to keep
redoing the scene and it was it was
definitely one of the worst days of my
life
so so it's all for
you